okay after eight grilling months I have
stopped working for Mr Beast holy
in this video I Give
[Music]
I give stress the the plane rise to
travel the winds the fails
true examination behind the curtain I'm
in Chile and I've got a new training
partner let's go he's gonna get jacked
this will be exciting perfect but first
the reason I stopped working for Mr
Beast is because
because I had a little baby boy meet
Seth today is his one week birthday so
technically I've only stopped or paused
working for Mr Beast for the next month
yes subtle clickbait but you can't get
triggered when looking at this cute
little face look look at this tiny nose
These Eyes hands and toes
so this is how we do it at Beast
everything I've learned over the past
eight months combined into five secret
never revealed before formulas on how to
make practically any video go viral even
if you only have one subscriber but
before going back it man's I have some
really exciting news along with House of
Max I have developed my very own Super
tasty caffeinated bar called the Brewer
my first ever product one of these bad
boys and you'll be wide awake and alert
for the entire day or night depending on
what you use it for I'll tell you more
about it at the end of this video but
it's by far the greatest thing I've ever
made and I'm super proud of it
okay so after finding out Gabby was
pregnant on a SAT phone in Antarctica I
flew back to South Africa and after 53
hours of grueling travel I made it to my
beautiful pregnant wife for a short trip
because I had to move to Greenville
North Carolina to start off my new
position as Chief creative officer at
Beast philanthropy which is a dream job
a once in a lifetime opportunity so
God's granted me three months three
months to fly there set up an entire
Studio to make it possible to work from
two opposite sides of the world so I
arrived at this undisclosed location
that was fully kitted out except for
this room
one day later with three Brew bars down
it became a pretty rad set up I'd say
this is where the next eight months of
chaos would begin then it was time for
me to fly back to Cape Town I set up
this studio along with a South African
team
I shot a form where we gave away 20 000
shoes to kids in need we got 20 million
views on this video success then back to
Greenville to shoot Mr Beast and Darren
on a blue screen for 3D comps that's
okay time to check in on Gabby and the
pregnancy
I wanted a boy
then to Cambodia to give away 2 000
Prosthetics to amputees in need then
back to South Africa to check on gabs as
well as where I lost debates and how to
get Darren's name tattooed on my
shoulder and then back to Greenville
North Carolina and did some yoga
two remote island Colombia to power it
and set up Wi-Fi and a bakery where I
fell in a river filled with crocodiles
in back to Cape Town where I broke my
wrist gotta go to Kenya in three days
I've been to Kenya to give away a bunch
of e-bikes to water delivery men and I
capsize another boat then back to Cape
Town where it was getting super close to
the birth so I quickly flew to the
Philippines to a children's hospital
where we paid for 150 surgeries and then
back to Cape Town just in time for the
birth it happened on the 18th of June
2023 which was Father's Day and that's
just something you can't script gabs
gave birth to the perfect little boy
named Seth
and that brings me to today what I've
learned working for Mr Beast over the
last eight months five hidden secrets he
has taught me to make anything go viral
even philanthropy videos which have in
the past been described as boring
they've been described as fatiguing
before taking this job most people told
me that this just wasn't gonna work
again just for the record I am still the
current chief creative officer of Beast
philanthropy I'm just taking some time
off a month or so to spend some valuable
time with my son
before I tell you the five hidden
secrets Mr Beast has taught me on how to
make literally any video go viral I want
to tell you more about brewbar the Brew
Bar was made in collaboration with House
of macadamias an incredible company with
a bunch of people I now consider really
close friends but most importantly they
are the best tasting nut of all time
this true so technically with the Brew
Bar we're kind of cheating because
macadamias are just so tasty so you can
add anything to it I don't know it still
tastes great this has been spoken about
by Joe Rogan House of macadamia Lex
Freedman House of macadamias and more
yeah I'm no health nut
but the blue ball contains rare omega-7s
which makes your skin glow and helps
with fat loss it increases gut health it
is super low carb it has heart healthy
fats and it is fully plant-based oh and
it has a ton of caffeine not too
much but just enough to give you a
really good kick
so click on the link in the top line of
the description to buy yours now the
first hundred people to buy two boxes of
Brew bars get a free variety pack of
additional House of macadamia bars as
well as free shipping and furthermore if
you use the code Brew I'll be donating
100 of the profits to Beast philanthropy
okay as promised Sierra the five never
taught before secrets to going viral Mr
Beast taught me while working with him
collaborate versus compete even though
he is the most followed individual on
YouTube he still never lets us get to
his head he understands that he is still
young and does not know everything often
times he leans on multiple mentors in
different fields of his company whether
it is business storytelling branding and
marketing psychology Etc he understands
he can no longer do it alone and that's
why he has more than 200 employees but
remember that he started all alone in
his bedroom many years ago with a super
shitty camera Jimmy often invites other
YouTubers around to Greenville whether
they are highly followed or have a micro
audience that he sees an X Factor to
learn from he values others opinions I
won't lie but before I started working
there I had a completely different idea
of Jimmy I just thought he was the kind
of person that told people what to do
and how to do it even with an
unfathomably brilliant mind he takes
advice from pretty much anyone and on
the other side of the coin he also gives
back by helping grow tons of others
channels by collaborating with him but
he constantly makes time to be involved
in other creators videos
whether it's short or longer form at the
end of the day the reason
with no argument the best in the world
is because he never stops learning and
he never lets himself believe that he is
indeed the best virality is not an
accident it's a skill as creators we
often blame the algorithm for not going
viral or for videos performing poorly to
your standard I know I do it's usually
the videos that I think are the best my
best videos get the least amount and
being friends with a lot of other
creators in the space this is like one
of the most common things with most of
us although the algorithm does have a
major part to play in the virality of
your content it is not the be-all and
end-all at the end of the day tough pull
to swallow here if your video did not
perform well it's on you not on the
algorithm one is that your shitty title
doesn't correlate with your thumbnail
which doesn't correlate with your first
sentence of your video two you can't
judge the Performance Based on your CTR
which is your clicky rate this does have
a minor role to play but it is not as
important as avd which is your average
view duration as well as the engagement
which on likes comments and shares good
what counts the most is how many people
click from the end of your video onto
another one this is super important if
you are the reason for someone staying
on YouTube for longer YouTube will favor
that three is dubbing in multiple
languages this is a no-brainer basically
the more languages your videos are
dubbed in equal the more amount of views
you're gonna get four something known as
the churn this means sticking to an
exact upload schedule at the exact time
we have worked out that every 21 days
works for the Beast philanthropy Channel
while Jimmy is in the process of testing
weekly when he can but he always uploads
at the same time on the same day and
lastly the length of the video as long
as the video is over 8 minutes and one
second long this gives YouTube the
ability to place two ads throughout the
video which it obviously prefers over
one identifiable characters throughout
all of Mr BEAST's videos they are the
same characters this helps the audience
develop personal relationships with not
just Mr Beast but he's Supporting Cast
as well they add the additional X Factor
and help with the banter this also
reaches a wider audience as there are so
many more character types to relate to
you can also play around with using the
most liked character later in your video
to up the ABD as there is an expectation
to see him or her in the video many
YouTubers use this technique to drive
the story forward a character gives us
the reason to care each time we see one
of these characters in the videos we
feel more involved in the main
character's Life As We somewhat
understand what it is like to be his or
her friend by doing this it definitely
makes your videos easier to make as is
less pressure on you to act alone
make movies to make money to make more
movies
this is something that Walt Disney said
but also an ethos that Jimmy lives by as
well as myself if the purpose of your
life of your content is to make
as many as possible you have to do
whatever it takes financially even if it
means using your entire budget obviously
outside of what you need to pay for your
day-to-day expenses or your monthly
overheads based
paid for anything you need to Outsource
the best investments you can make in the
creative industry is in your personal
brand
story equals retention the number one
rule I have is that story comes first
however story is a very misunderstood
term stories have to have four elements
one identifiable characters two
significant moments three authentic
emotions and four specific details you
have to ask yourself what is the story
that you're trying to tell what is the
emotion that you're trying to convey how
are you going to convey this emotion to
the audience and Jimmy has started to
adapt and evolve his content by adding
more story to it previously although his
philanthropy videos had great ideas they
lacked in story as well as aesthetic one
of the reasons he brought me onto the
philanthropy channel was to try and
convey the emotion that these films
deserve to have to actually make the
audience feel something Jimmy is now
trying to bring more of the storytelling
approach into the main Channel videos
developing a story will not only create
a more complete video but it will also
help build retention storytelling
techniques like foreshadowing and
conflict allow the audience to stay
engaged until the end of the film this
also gives his videos more structure and
at the end of the day a good story just
makes the videos so much more pleasant
to watch and will make your content
stand out from all the others on YouTube
go to the end of this video please let
me know by writing Brew bar or something
about the Brew Bar in the comments below
and I'll be giving away one thousand
dollars to one lucky person that
comments that below again a huge huge
shout out to House of macadamias for
making the Brew Bar possible click on
the link below to purchase yours now
like click on it right now purchase it
other than that don't forget you're
awesome brew and I'll see you soon for a
new video but for now you can keep up to
date with me and my missions on the bees
for land B Channel
bye
[Music]